the bases are loaded the shot clock is
running out the judges are starting to
notice you've been getting vaccinated
behind the bleachers between rounds with
a mysterious glowing blue formula and
the opposing team are sharpening their
hockey sticks at the other end for some
street rules you've never been a
particularly good swimmer but football
is in your blood so by god you're going
to get this free throw to pay for your
father's new cybernetic leg after his
thresher accident on the farm blast you
make the shot and it's a foul ball that
spirals straight into little timmy's
glove in the fourth row
your one chance to make it all come
together and you blew it as the home
team dumps gatorade on their towel boy
and a swell of applause and victory
cheers your used and abused super
soldier body begins to succumb to the
organ failure that's a virtual certainty
after 19 months of injecting pure
electrified antifreeze into your
bloodstream to build up a tolerance to
all forms of physical violence you drop
to your knees on the grass and find your
vision fading to a white void where you
can finally be at peace knowing you'll
just be doing this all over again in
nine to fifteen years anyway but with
ray tracing next time
welcome to
the gutter space
the only pop culture news show where you
can comment your greatest fears and
weaknesses and be sure the host won't
exploit it to destroy your political
career you can trust me man i got your
back comic book video games tmnt
shredders revenge has casey jones and
you can get a free pizza with a physical
copy of the game and that's sick i like
that i like ninja turtles midnight sons
has another cg trailer that shows off
venom and spiderman sleeves are gone
again
venom gets mind-controlled and turned
into a giant symbiote demon thing and
that's
that's just swell it's a good excuse to
have him fight spider-man without
undermining the fact that they've been
bros for like decades now in the comics
i really enjoy that the soundtrack is
blaring metallica bookending the trailer
i miss when video games had guitars in
the soundtrack other than doom
nowadays everything is underscored with
indistinguishable boring orchestra music
that all sounds the same like the middle
of this trailer
but then they bring out the amps this is
the song that plays in my head when i
look at that power strip i plug my phone
into
master
master
this trailer is awesome and gets me so
hyped but then i remember what the
gameplay is going to look like and then
i get kinda sad because that doesn't
doesn't really
look
awesome
but you know what makes me even more sad
crime do you know what the fastest
growing crime in america is identity
theft claims a new victim every 14
seconds just a few years ago my mom's
bank card number was stolen and someone
in europe spent 300 out of her account
buying a new tv and we just wish we
could have caught it sooner
that's why i'm excited to talk about
today's sponsor aura aura is an identity
theft protection fraud monitoring
password management anti-virus software
all combined into one simple easy to use
app you might have one of these service
individually already but it's like
locking the front door and leaving the
back door wide open instead of logging
into your email one day finding out your
password was changed hours ago and
getting some shady notifications from
the activity on your bank or a monitor
is the deep web for your emails
passwords and social security numbers to
send you alerts fast to your phone and
email i tried it out and was shocked to
find that a few of my passwords had
already been compromised including that
wattpad account i made like six years
ago to read my friend brandon's batman
fanfic not my wattpad aura also gives
you real-time alerts on suspicious
credit inquiries like if someone was
opening a loan or credit card in your
name and their vpn service allows you to
stay anonymous by keeping your browsing
history and personal information safe
and encrypted
protect your family and yourself from
identity theft at aura.com forward slash
godzilla with my link in the description
and if you sign up right now you can try
out a two-week free trial to see how
many times aura finds you or your family
member's personal info on the dark web
if you sign up now let me know in the
comments if your personal information
has been compromised you won't regret
checking now back to the video new
spider-man fortnite skin it keeps
happening you bastards on the spider-man
subreddit or whatever can make fun of me
all you want you know i'm right 2023 is
going to be a good year for dead space
fans and i think we deserve it after
that 10-year long drought
some of the original dead space devs are
working on the spiritual successor to
the series the callisto protocol which
is apparently no longer in the pub g
universe that's weird i don't know why
it was in the first place that has a new
gameplay trailer showing a spaceman on a
spaceship chopping limbs off monsters
throwing them around with electric
telekinesis and then stomping corpses
before being gruesomely killed in an
elaborate death animation
pretty dead spacey it'll be out in
december just before the new year and if
that's not enough motive studios are
over here remaking the first dead space
in loving detail for 2023 too initially
i thought this remake was weird because
the first game has aged pretty well but
i played it for the hundredth time last
week and i realized its character models
are kind of plastic looking its controls
were far more refined in the sequels and
the story of the overall series suffers
from making isaac a silent protagonist
and then giving up on that right away so
you don't get attached to him as soon as
you need to for him to be the central
character of the entire franchise it'd
be cool to run through the original game
again with isaac allowed to speak this
time and play more of a role in the
story with his original voice actor mind
you and an insane level of polish to the
graphics and mechanics like look at this
[ __ ] that they did for his breathing
i would have honestly just settled for a
remaster but i don't know some of the
changes they've made sound pretty cool
and if this has a chance of
reinvigorating the series after dead
space 3 definitively [ __ ] murdered it
then by all means i just want more dead
space i like scary stuff on spaceships
and
this is my time
oh yeah fort solas and routine are
coming out too
what
as we all know dead space is
mechanically an evolution of the third
person horror gameplay of resident evil
4. everything old is new again let's all
wear some bell bottoms i've explained in
detail in the past that i don't think
resident evil 4 remake is a necessary
thing because the old one is still solid
doesn't really need any updates to its
story and was getting ported to more
machines than [ __ ] skyrim and i feel
like this remake is a lot easier to mess
up than the previous ones for various
reasons primarily because capcom doesn't
make one-to-one remakes of their
previous games you know if it was a good
game 10 years ago and you just do
exactly that again then it'll be a good
game but prettier but they're internally
referred to as reimaginings so there's
so much more room for error because
they're not just following the blueprint
of an already awesome game they're
trying to reinvent the wheel a little
and that can have varied results i think
resident evil 2 remake was awesome
because of the changes it made i think
resident evil 3 remake actually fell a
little bit short of the original because
it was just
smaller
and not as fun i'm ultimately still down
to try it out and play it until my eyes
bleed because i love resin evil 4 and if
they nail this it'll be a cool new way
to experience the leon doesn't care
adventure featuring europe
my biggest hope for this remake is that
it doesn't completely overshadow the
original and they just stop allowing you
to play that on future generations of
consoles re1 through 3 classic can only
be bought and played today on the ps3
store and that was almost shut down last
year until everyone rioted and brought
it some extra time i love the original
re4 and i think it really does stand the
test of time so i hope this new spin
recaptures everything that made it good
without making it totally obsolete in
the process
which is an extremely tall order which
is why of all the game remakes coming
out this is the one that has me the most
concerned but only out of love you know
the resident evil 8 dlc story looks
pretty cool probably has to be extremely
self-contained from the rest of resident
evil lore because it takes place in like
2035 and the rest of the series probably
doesn't want to have to be beholden to
what that's doing for the next 15 years
but hey third person mode for the main
game and the dlc is an interesting touch
it'll be cool to do a new playthrough
with that perspective you can also play
as a 9 foot tall vampire woman if that's
a thing for you so
yeah
in other video game remake news by god
it feels like we're in the late 2000s
platinum dunes era all over again the
last of us is receiving another shiny
new update on the engine from the second
game this one feels especially weird
because the original still holds up to
modern graphical standards way better
than most games getting remakes around
this time and it's not even a full 10
years old yet and they already did the
remaster for ps4 and that looks pretty
good but in spite of everything we're
getting a third version of this game and
in some of the side-by-side comparisons
for the gameplay it feels like the only
difference is the characters are
standing in slightly different lighting
maybe the hair on the new models looks
nicer i guess
other screenshots it actually looks like
a pretty night and day difference i
don't know it's a little bit of a mixed
bag it is cool however that the new
in-game models now match the quality of
the ones from the pre-rendered cutscenes
and it'll take out all those hard
transitions from game to story i really
like the last of us and i think it's a
great game but i have no idea why it
needs to keep getting polished and
updated over and over instead of simply
just being ported i mean i would have
just played another port that's fine
i guess the idea is to add in mechanics
from the second game to make playing
them back to back more coherent but even
that doesn't feel totally necessary just
let the games evolve as you play them
they don't need to be exactly the same
functionally i guess it would be cool if
they expanded levels to be much larger
with more exploration i can't afford a
ps5 because i'm a broke [ __ ] so it'll
be ages before i can ever even play this
but i might check it out someday if you
weren't tired of that same story being
done again and again here's some behind
the scenes of the last of us tv show yet
another show about pedro pascal being a
reluctant dad on a road trip adventure
with a special child seeing as how the
game was already a really well told
story it seems redundant to just do that
again but without the interactive
element included in a way less
technically impressive way it's on the
same level of pointlessness as the
live-action disney remakes of animated
movies why have a talented team of
hundreds of animators work hard to make
expressive and lifelike characters in an
unforgettable immersive world when you
can just point a camera at actors in a
park in canada it works so great for
bebop speaking of live-action hollywood
adaptations making their source material
less desirable for casual audiences
through their convenience and mainstream
appeal comic book movies black adam has
its first full trailer i want to hate on
this movie because i feel like they're
going to wuss out of making black adam
too villainous because he's played by
charismatic actor dwayne johnson
but this movie's been a passion project
of his for like 15 years so clearly he
loves the character and i'll give him a
chance i feel like he'll
try to do the right thing by black adam
fans all six of you it's cool seeing
that all these other characters like
hawkman dr fate and adam smasher are
there too i hope adam smasher smashes
black adam and then the adam and captain
adam show up from the future with adam
strange i can't wait for this guy to
slap around all those goofy children in
shazam three that'll be fun the entire
collective internet spammed unfunny
morbius memes so hard they communally
tricked sony studios into thinking that
was a huge demand for morbius to come
back to theaters and on its second run
it made about 85 000
nationwide making it the first movie to
bomb in theaters twice
so sony needs rent money and are putting
out no way home again with a clunky
title and a bunch of deleted scenes they
lied about putting in the home release
hopefully this will be more interesting
content than a half rendered ps2 hulk
from end game highest grossing movie of
all time you [ __ ] couldn't afford to
finish that cheap moth [ __ ] they
announced joker 2 with a pretentious
title that implies that more than one
person will be a joker this time so
either harley quinn will show up
or there will be a damn copycat joker
from that thing willem dafoe pitched a
while back
it's weird how long it's been since
joker and batman have been against each
other in a film they're pretty much just
separate movie franchises that
occasionally cross over now wait update
apparently lady gaga is in talks to
co-star in it might play harley quinn
joaquin phoenix isn't totally for sure
on board yet and it's also
apparently a musical
uh
are we are we being pranked is is that
real
and on the tv front gotham knights no
relation to the game is a cw show about
batman dying or disappearing so it's up
to someone else to take over as gotham's
protector but it's different from those
this one has no budget so batman's
costume is hilariously embarrassing and
the main character is an adopted son of
bruce wayne that's an original character
instead of any of his dozens of kids in
the comics
now lame oc that's probably the joker's
biological son for a plot twist midway
through the season or some [ __ ] must
team up with what appears to be a group
of annoying edgy teenagers to avenge
batman and
i i don't care i'm not gonna watch this
next you guys know i like alien and
predator right i did the aliens games
the predator games and the aliens and
predator games which got way less views
even though it was highly requested in
the comments of the other two which is
why i don't do requested topics anymore
because you guys ask for stuff and then
don't watch it new aliens game already
this is the spiritual successor to
aliens black plague and aliens penumbra
two minutes and 28 seconds of a
cinematic trailer with stiff facial
animation just to show off exactly five
seconds of gameplay footage how
exciting looks like a top-down strategy
game thing
god what do i have to do to get alien
isolation too i'm not above ritual human
sacrifice to appease h.r giger's
menacing demonic spirit at least
predators got some cool [ __ ] coming down
the pipe with that new movie titled prey
which has assuredly upset some bethesda
collaborators working on a straight to
dvd game adaptation like doom
annihilation my personal formula for how
to make a cool predator movie is not to
make it explicitly about the predators
and their lore but to make an unrelated
gritty action movie that would work
entirely on its own without a predator
but it just makes the situation more
complicated and exciting when one shows
up and hijacks the plot halfway through
the first one's still an interesting
movie about dutch schaefer realizing his
search and rescue squad was manipulated
by the government to do a search and
destroy mission because of cold war era
politics and his faith in his country is
shaken and then an alien with lasers
shows up it's [ __ ] awesome the second
movie is halfway to being a lethal
weapon movie with danny glover as a
loose cannon cop trying to stop la from
collapsing because of a war between the
jamaican and colombian cartels brewing
over turf disputes then an alien with
laser shows up and it's [ __ ] awesome
if this new one can follow suit and be a
really cool movie on its own where the
predator is icing on the cake then it'll
be a worthy entry into the franchise
predator 2018 is a terrible terrible
awful thing the predators want to
accelerate climate change bruh
resident evil is getting a netflix show
i cancelled my netflix a few months ago
because their service becomes worse by
the month so i'm not even sure i'll
watch this once again it's another
attempt to bring resident evil to live
action by just writing whatever the [ __ ]
they feel like for the story and then
cramming in recognizable monsters
iconography and locations to try and
make up for writing terrible fan fiction
now wesker has two daughters you've
never heard of instead of his son that
you never heard of that are trying to
survive the zombie apocalypse while
having flashbacks to their dad doing
supervillain [ __ ] that ended the world
even though a full-on zombie apocalypse
never actually happens in the games this
and the alice movies seem to think
walking dead knockoff [ __ ] is the way to
go
it turns out man was the greatest
monster
i know he doesn't look like wesker but i
think of all the actors cast as him so
far lance reddick is the one that could
genuinely pull off his personality and
cool factor and anything's a step up
from the welcome to raccoon city version
i want to do a whole video on that movie
i think it's just
fascinatingly wrong in every way
sonic frontiers showed some gameplay and
then everyone got mad i think and then
maybe they were gonna delay it and then
they were like no we're not gonna delay
it i don't know and then they showed
some more gameplay and then everyone's
like not mad anymore um i i don't know i
don't really have a horse in this race i
don't play sonic games i'll defer to
jacob on that one what's what's the
prognosis doc no delay yet but a lot of
people were asking for one when the
first look fans got it the new mainline
sonic game in 5 years looked extremely
boring and rough around the edges
we got pop in we got a complete lack of
physics requiring sonic to boost
downhill to get any sort of speed
whatsoever and some clunky looking
combat
i really hope this is more fun than it
looks
our first look at this game has been
stretched throughout the month via ign
coverage this has been one of the
weirdest marketing fumbles i have ever
seen by trying to play it close to the
chest they have left fans high and dry
for almost a year having nothing to go
off of but an 8 second cinematic of
sonic running through the woods courtesy
of the first sonic central which is
basically like a nintendo direct but
only for sonic my dream and then an
entire year later with the return of
sonic central they sat around and
announced literally nothing for 15
minutes as ign showed off gameplay for
sonic frontiers at the exact same moment
in a different stream on a completely
different channel
what
and that's where all the fan backlash
came from but then like a week later we
found out that it was just an early
build that we were seeing and uh whoever
was playing it was just clearly not very
good at it because they showed some
footage right after that just looked
much better and whoever was playing was
actually competent and it didn't look
nearly as boring i still got problems
for sure but why didn't you lead with
this
so far what we know the story is that
it'll be penned by ian flynn of archie
comics and idw sonic fame and i couldn't
be more thrilled about that i highly
recommend the idw sonic comic series
it's so good it's great like please go
read it the story of sonic frontiers
will follow sonic tails and amy getting
sucked into some kind of portal and
being transported to a mysterious new
land the cast will all have amnesia upon
waking up it seems like the name of this
new land might be the star fall islands
i think somewhere takashi azuka the head
of like sonic team mentioned that the
game will be made up of different
islands that you can visit and journey
through so far we've only seen one and
it's
probably one of the more boring ones
also like knuckles is going to be
important i think like look he's
actually doing his job for the first
time since like 2001 that's cool i like
that so uh there's your little sonic
update whatever i don't know if i'll be
doing more of these uh i think i just
kind of got roped into this like a me
seeks box
five nights at freddy's security breach
is getting a dlc so big news for theory
man and marky guy the main game was
pretty rough so hopefully this is more
polished than
not at all i have a passing interest in
this series but i'm a bit hesitant to
care because it seems like they're
becoming more and more kitty and less
about genuinely scary and unsettling
concepts so i don't know maybe i'm
getting too old to be the
main audience for this anymore i mean i
wasn't i was i was like
perfect in like 2014.
i think that's all for announcements
that i care to talk about at this time
what game or movies are you most excited
wait wait the spot is in spider-verse 2.
what games or movies are you most
excited for coming up you want to hear
me talk about the resident evil movie i
want to taco i don't want to really do
that if you want a bigger but more
short-term way to help support the
channel and help us thrive go check out
my ebay where i'm selling a bunch of
rare collectibles and toys i've found
that are in really good condition
otherwise be sure to hit up the patreon
and check out some patreon exclusive
videos dropping there it's only a dollar
and it really helps us out see you next
time
[Music]
you